My name is Branson, Sir Richard Branson.
And as founder of the Virgin Group, I've been in my share of compromising positions.
I've usually gotten out of them with a little luck.
People ask me "Your Excellency, how do you always end up on top?"
And the answer is, I don't.
Sometimes I end up in the mouth of a whale shark.
But enough about me.
Here is my guide to getting lucky at 35,000 feet.
First, pinpoint the object of your affection.
Once the seatbelt sign is off, approach her with a check for her favorite charity.
Carry it in the mouth of a puppy that you've given the power of speech to.
Direct her attention to the window where she will see...
...your suborbital spaceship, composing a haiku in sky writing.
Drive to your launch pad, pole vault her into the basket of your hot air balloon,...
...and take flight to your private island.
If you need a more cost-effective alternative,...
...try treating her or him to something delicious...
...using the new seat-to-seat feature of Red,...
...the Virgin America in-flight entertainment system.
Just order a drink, meal or snack.
Select his or her seat....
...and don't forget to seal the deal with a suggestive seat-to-seat chat.
I'm not a betting man but I say your chances of deplaning with a plus-one...
...are at least 50 percent.
Best of luck out there.
Cheers.